assistants maternels s'écrit souvent
féminins mais désormais grâce à la mam
de s'entendre et le masculin
définitivement adopté la maison
d'assistants maternels la castille
marmaille a retenu cette originalité en
plus de louise christine et amandine il
faudra aussi compter avec david semblait
etc afin de voir ma femme travaille avec
les enfants les jours j'ai donc et ça me
plaît j'aime bien les enfants
apparemment je m'épanouis dans ce type
il maisons d'assistants maternels mixte
la conseillère départementale a souligné
cette première sur toute l'île pour vous
qualifier d'une mam mixte puisque nous
comptons un homme qui est très peu
commun dans ce métier j'ai envie de vous
dire monsieur que vous avez fait un
choix courageux et admirable une maison
où mettre les compétences en commun mais
surtout pour sortir de l'isolément de la
mission d'assistance maternelle comme
christine qui en appartement avait du
mal à exercer sa profession
jaar où j'habitais j'avais du mal à
pouvoir travailler
on s'est jeté dans un appartement
n'avait déjà discuté ça fait un bon
moment avec des collègues mais après on
a monté le projet passera mal pris du
temps mais maintenant c'est un petit con
a fait la solidarité puisqu'on
additionnant tous les agréments nos
quatre assistants maternels peuvent
accueillir jusqu'à 13 marmaille la
maison d'assistants maternels permet
aussi cela obtenir de nouveaux agréments
on a choisi la main pour justement que
monsieur compagne puisse travailler
qu'elles n'avaient pas la possibilité
d'avoir l'agrément
domicile et en même temps ça a permis à
deux autres assistants maternels d'avoir
des places supplémentaires qui
n'auraient pas pu obtenir alors donné
c'est le métier d'assistant maternel est
une véritable vocation il exerçait en
main permet de continuer à faire du
périscolaire comme moi j'ai aussi des
périscolaires aussi
aller chercher à l'école et tout ça du
coulage maintenant je peux laisser avec
mes collègues les autres et qu'ils
allaient chercher alors que c'est à
l'école donc quand c'est moins
contraignant si une structure qui plaît
aux parents surtout attiré par la vie en
communauté que propose la même on a
choisi en fait c'est notre à stoke
maternelle qui nous en a parlé
effectivement nous sommes déjà bien que
venus parce qu'on trouvait que c'était
un très bon compromis
votre prise en charge individuelle ou
les grands parents avaient quand même
son assistante maternelle et en même
temps l'apprentissage de la vie en
collectivité qui va bien nous préparer à
l'école donc pour nous c'était vraiment
idéal et on l'accompagné notre assistant
qu'internet dans ce projet là avec
dix-huit maisons d'assistants maternels
à la réunion le conseil départemental
offre la possibilité à travers ses
structures d'une prise en charge
différente pour permettre aux assistants
maternels de sortir de chez eux et de
mettre en commun leurs savoir faire